[Music]
hello looking for Lobby GameSpot's
weekly hangout every Tuesday at 2 p.m.
Pacific right here on GameSpot calm I'm
your host Daniel Dwyer joined this week
Chris waters isn't here oh my god that
doesn't matter we got the original
operation Anchorage right here Justin
hey wall how do you deal my friend I'm
good and the pride of Utah Antibes Allen
hey what up how are you great and first
off I want to talk about a little thing
called 4k oh yes you made feature last
week on gamespot.com I delve into that
[ __ ] you did you you you made a great
excuse to play as many games in the
workplace as possible oh I'm so busy I
have to play this but it's for Gators no
I'll do myself all in the all in the the
the aim of answering one question is 4k
worth ish and so first of all Justin
actually what is 4k for those who are
uninitiated houses mean I I think that
it's something from the future yeah so
right now we're in 2k yeah we you know
we're previously in 1k or in 4000 to K
games and we've pulled technology from
2000 years in the future and that's all
a 4k that's right Matt this up video
games looked like 2,000 years in the
future I'm gonna be bummed
at 4k is how many lines of resolution we
talking about it uh 2160 so 2160
vertical so it's about four times reads
it's exactly four times ten eighty okay
so you can fit for 1080 screens in one
4k screen alright so you played a bunch
of games on in 4k last week yeah
captured a little footage what games did
you play okay I got my notes you got
your notes because I played a lot okay
actually yeah I played Wolfenstein yeah
I played far cry 4 project cars dirt
rally GTA 5 and The Witcher 3 which are
all games I've been playing a lot lately
not in 4k yes so I could have like a
frame of reference going into it I don't
support that right like 4k is it's not
like you can just play an nes game I
don't like oh it's 4k yeah I don't know
about that
like who knows these are all games daily
no games that will scale maybe that
natively had it in them
well then whether or not the textures
yeah are at 4k resolution that's a
lesser story like I don't know what's
what's going on behind the scenes yeah
[ __ ] throw nades way but uh I know
what's going on in the
menu yeah I'll let you select 4k so you
figure all right before we get into yeah
how it looks it's all it's subjective
I'll say that yeah I had a different
experience than like gar say our man
Josh branding the track don't worry
we'll get into that yeah I want to
talked about that let's let's have a
look at the technology first all right
you but you bought a couple of treats
your here's what I wanted to cover hmm
to run 4k we have this beast of a
machine yeah it's it's an alienware
alpha I think it's called or something
like that anyway area 51 yeah I mean the
alphas the little guy thanks bro yeah
it's like $4,500 yes yes for three gtx
980 is running an SLI which is possibly
the best 4k solution here's the sexy
shots that Josh Shaw took of it for the
residual cards you can find on our
website
three 980 s which is like B car right
now right it's like the best card
besides the Titan X yes okay which is a
single card basically solution for doing
this super high stuff like 4k this is
$1,000 I just looked at the price for
the show ten fifty one thousand dollars
fifty couldn't even shave off that 51
just thought I'd given my Chilean on the
980 s are five hundred sixty dollars
each each right now okay so two of those
will have probably outperform one of
those right but you're still paying a
little bit more um okay but come on to
that yes Kay this is the problem is the
cost is super high no no it is already
average car exactly yeah you need to get
a Model T you need to have and now for
the monitors so we did our testing on
this guy which is a Acer as you can see
thank you just a gaming monitor 28 and
28 inches for okay 60 Hertz okay pretty
good yeah it's pretty self juicing right
I don't want to get into deep into that
but it adds about two hundred and thirty
dollars to the cost of the monitor
g-sync juicing get this monitor for four
hundred and fifty dollars without
juicing okay
and you can get it for 680 something
concerned $84 with g-sync what is it
what is different what is did you think
is it's some sort of okay so g-sync
works with other Nvidia for stuff yeah
and Vegas stuff and it kind of it makes
it so if your monitor drops if your
frame rate drops below the refresh rate
of the monitor say 60 in this case if
you're running like 40
GC kind of takes over for vsync and is
doesn't skip it doesn't make like a
Skippy motion like the velodrome so it
eliminates fraying tear frame tearing
yeah
visually and it eliminates the frame
skipping but you can feel and see you
know in the game and it seems to
actually work like I've seen demos where
they show off like here's G sink on G
sink off for you've been doing it much
more extensively than I have do you feel
like it actually adds to it so no but I
again it's there's probably deeper stuff
to get into it you sink and in our case
running SLI there's juicing stuff in the
drivers gives performance hookah so I
turn it off to get the highest
performance I could get and honest I
didn't see any screen tearing on that
model some people are more sensitive to
that than other sort of resolution
versus frame race but when we when we
captured the output of those three g9
80s or whatever on a device we had
called the Shogun was the whole
different thing there was massive screen
tearing or on that thing which it wasn't
showing up on that monitor so maybe that
monitor is dude was running do you think
and I just didn't know it what about
this guy okay this is this is you want
to talk about like smudging my Trojan
horse for this piece okay to talk about
high frame rate okay with just almost
it's like the opposite side of the
argument but yeah it goes back to like
the age-old PC gaming debate of do you
want to have more pixels on a monitor or
do you want to run fast exactly and in
the era of like LCD panels we cannot we
kind of lost that everything's 60 yeah
yeah we kind of just said 60 is the
highest thing you can get yes frames a
second like consoles are trying to get
their consoles have to like sacrifice
together right run at 60 I remember
having CRT monitors that were like 120
Hertz I guess 21 inch and that was like
and we were like happy back then but
then you can kind of like it gave you
like a headache sometimes it wasn't
perfect oh it sucked one of those
filters on it where if I touch the gimme
stock Sean yeah it's gotta be ghazal
yeah yeah but anyway so monitors have
started coming out super high for every
monitor 144 Hertz
so it's 144 which is true Hertz like you
see all this BS mark yes all over TVs
that's like 100 for the head ones for 3d
so I don't know if those were like
really running out of court they're like
doing something there's a whole lot of
spirit down
middle when it's 3d it's like it's like
so it's but this is like yes the
framerate is that high and boy can you
tell the difference I can the can is
subjective right playing this game dirt
rally which is phenomenal game early
access um at over a hundred frames per
second yeah was game changing literally
like I played the getting better because
I could see things happening like it was
smoother I was like e breaking power
sliding way better I don't know why
maybe it was just a feeling was better
and I wasn't really playing better but I
it was so cool it's one of those games
where you are like looking at a
specially driving games where you're
looking at a point in the distance which
is quite far away so like having that
little bit of reaction time my mind and
even in Far Cry 4 just seeing the
bullets hitting and like being able to
react faster it was smooth when you
would do like a 180 was just so cool
like there's something unexplainable
that just makes you feel amazing when
you're playing it over sixteen you know
there's probably internet debates about
if I can't see past six yeah I totally
can 100 frames hundred plus all the
weight 244 it's incredible I thought I
would much rather go for high frame rate
than 4k at this point but I think I feel
like this is like the the blue and black
gold and white dress of [ __ ] video
games because there seems to go on
forever where people are like like when
I was like looking at the 4k stuff when
you showed me that it was like some of
those like and you ain't even into like
parchment cards at 100 frames no not
that's the way that as much as I was but
I think framerate is always where I've
landed on it like I feel like the
arguments on on forums for years and
they're just everywhere is it's it's an
age-old debate that almost says
something it's just so personal
preference II to Justin where you land
on this whole thing you know for me it's
something that it's so new that and
there's not a lot of games that
necessarily take that much advantage of
it and and you look at all this extra
stuff you have to to throw on so we grab
to make it work like yeah does that
price really I'm add to that much more
of your enjoyment I mean yeah cuz PC
gaming is cool like I I want to know
what's beyond 1080p60 like and so I
wanted to achieve I see it and it's
amazing like like you know how people
talk about this stuff all over like 900
people on the Xbox
we're hitting
like you know really high knew these
consoles and they get really passionate
about it I kind of like didn't I was
like always not like understanding why
they were getting so up and now I'm like
the one that's gonna be like no I need
144 today there's also a 2k monitor
that's $800 that runs 144 that seems to
be the pinnacle of pinnacle cheese Amiga
rise to get that cuz running 2 K is
pretty good on even like a 970 really uh
yeah Oh see that's where I'm on yeah I
say these are the type of games I play
actually probably matter a lot more like
I love shooters I love car games I love
yeah action games
I love City skylines what kinda game is
that that pride doesn't matter no so so
manner in modesty you're in what may be
in 4k that looks amazing I'm sure I
didn't I'm sure and you know what this
is ever problem is what I'm sure if you
bought a 4k confers cards and a monitor
you make sure that everything looks
great even if it doesn't you tell
everyone it looks great
I got no buyer's remorse over here
here's an interesting side note we ran I
was like Mortal Kombat's gonna be great
at 100 frames per second it was capped
at 60 because I guess where the fighting
is just that's part of the design so
maybe this is something we can look
forward to two years down the road or at
least PC gamers can look for yeah tears
on the road this is probably gonna look
with it I didn't really get into like
what 4k looks like mmm it looks it
doesn't add let me tell my
interpretation of it and everybody was
different of course because we all have
like different things we care about
we're playing on a monitor that's like
28 inches that close up your desktop is
unusable right yeah that small
everything is tiny but once you load up
the game and stuff it scales but then
every all the objects and everything in
the game take on this form that you're
like whoa I can like grab that so so it
seems like it's something that's like so
Chris it's less important for for that
console like spirit sitting in front of
your monitor experience but when we
start getting into VR when those
experiences get bigger and bigger and
cheaper like then 4k feels like it's
going to be incredibly important oh yeah
like because then you'll be right in
your foot is the massive part the
problem we have a new oculus is that
they're splitting this one halfway down
already like they can't get the rod
that's a conversation for another day
Andy what's the name of the feature
people can watch on GameSpot all about I
think I ended up naming at 4k gaming how
cool is it okay or something like that
and the answer is awesomely cool
especially our friend Josh in there
that's gotta say before love
The Witcher 3 at forque yeah he was like
it and I didn't look at it because I'm
playing on an Xbox one
do my dope I won't yeah do not poison
well cannot go back I said so if you
want to watch the feature table on
GameSpot calm right now and let us know
in the comments what you think I'm sure
he will I'm sure the PC crowd will let
us know
[Music]